I'm G fueled up sponsored ladies and gentlemen
get yourself a cheap field today 20 off with our
promo code in the description box guys we got
ourselves a trailer for The Flash and despite
any earlier controversies that have been talked
about I am looking forward to this film finally
coming out it looks like it's finally coming here
it's gotta be the greatest film of all time yeah
and like Coy said earlier we are the cast of
Flashpoint right here of this new Flash movie
Ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead and leave a
like that would mean the world to us if you could
go ahead and do that also uh Coy and John they
finally watched the Justice League Flashpoint
movie right here on this channel so you guys
can go ahead and check that out at some point
and we're going to cover whatever else comes out
of the Super Bowl we'll be a little bit selective
today so subscribe click that notification Bell
to get notified when a reaction is up or whatever
else might pique your interest you guys excited
I'm super excited I'm really excited too people
tell me something you can go anywhere
save your mommy online
Another Universe
fight to save this one it's definitely Affleck
yeah it's definitely this is the world where my
mom lives I don't lose her again oh no Ron
Livingston oh Ron Livingston's the dad now
yeah the only product couldn't do it time has a
pattern great cast that it can't help reliving
interesting people different
worlds oh drawn to each other like
no oh my face so my face
he's turning his powers back you can also
destroy just kept me happening this is odd
I completely broke the universe it's enormous
whoa damn created a world with no meta-humans
and now there's no one to defend us fascinating
foreign
it back
a future
holy [__] oh they're gonna
do this thing damn dude
high beams what's the plate Batman
what do we do we try not to die
oh [__] wow There She Goes wow
it's not quark my name is Kara Barry
what are you doing our kids
are gonna want to see this
wow oh my yeah I love the trailer I also feel
like I kind of pieced together the whole film
sure I mean is that not what full trailers
especially in this universe it seems what I
like about the change from Flashpoint is you know
because when Barry Allen time travels in that he
just replaces other Barry Allen right whereas
here he's confronting the Barry Allen before
Barry Allen had powers looks like that Barry Allen
did never became the Flash and then they do the
thing they do in Flashpoint where he gets Powers
but it's not he tries to get the powers yeah it
looks like the thing with the batarang like having
Flashpoint when he a Batman tries to get him his
powers back it looks like that's that was the
moment but it's the other Berry in this one
yeah he's getting so there's two flashes like we
saw well I imagine that our I'll I'll go by saying
like 2022 Barry or what year were we in 2023
well also 2023 Barry is the current you know DC
EU one yeah I think it looked like 2023 Barry goes
back probably loses his powers like how in the it
goes in the comic and then he's so he's trying to
regain so I see some of the reset of the timeline
by trying to get the 2013 bury that and instead
of breaking out Cal L to rescue him who's been
in prison it's clearly Cara right and it's taking
place so then they gotta go fight Zod together all
the end because they don't have a Superman yeah
and I guess I don't know exactly how it ends but
I feel like the most of the movies that's pretty
much the rest of the movie right so the question
is is like will he he's probably going to have to
make that choice whether or not that's where I'm
like conflicted on I imagine that he will make the
choice to ultimately not save his mom let her live
because he's got to keep some things in order
because imagine some of this is about maturing
yeah and like a coming-of-age story of sorts and
then a new timeline will be established at the
very end yeah yeah um but it's still a great truth
I want to see all that play out that I just said
like I want to see all that play out um it looks
awesome uh but yo guys who wants to hand up first
let's talk about Keaton I mean it wasn't George
Clooney but you know I'll accept Michael Keaton
and Ben Affleck I mean that was cool because
there's been so much up in the air about like
what if they shot what if they reshot who's gonna
appear and this was cool because I feel like on
the one hand you'd want Batman to be a surprise
but here I was like cool we got two flashes we got
two Batman we got Zod like this feels very big and
connected in a way that is probably gonna confuse
some people because of the resetting of the Snyder
verse but also this looks very much ripped out
of that aesthetic and I love just seeing Michael
Keaton back in the suit obviously seeing the kind
of attitude just getting those hints of the growth
of his character since the last time we saw him in
Batman Returns and uh it doesn't look goofy at all
no no it never looks really badass they shot it
very bertinely too yeah sure the first time we see
him in the trailer even and there's like a burton
like where he does that pivot tilt where he like
swoops and I love that it feels like Batman 3 in
those moments and I'm really wondering how much of
that plays into much Yeti's directing style when
he's directing like will he have Cavill I mean
sorry everyone we only have uh bat Fleck feel
like Snyder shots will he have Burton feel like
those shots and will it feel like the Multiverse
of directing because yeah this this is allowing
us to meld universes and I think that's going to
help people from not be too confused as to the
Snyder implosion is because you're bringing in
both Keaton and batflick and therefore you could
shoot it in different ways multiversely yeah and
that'd be really fun and it looks like they did
that because those couple shots of him on the on
the Bat Bike feel very very Snyder oh definitely
well it looks like in the beginning of this he's
probably working with the Justice League or just
Batman I imagine like will there be more Justice
League cameos at the beginning yeah Aquaman will
there be Wonder Woman there in the city whatever
fight is going down where he's on the Bat Bike
and like yeah you got Bruce Wayne and Ben Affleck
warning him at the top like you probably should
in time travel but he's gonna make that choice
anyway because that's such a Learning lesson
for Barry in the flashpoint storyline and so
I'm really liking this and honestly it looks
very um the flashpoint storyline is also very
emotional because it's the hardest Choice the guy
has to make he has to basically choose whether or
not he's going to let his mom live or die yeah
and he's also dealing with the fact that his
dad is in jail and he wants to prove that his
dad is actually Innocent but the thing that I
was that I did not get from this trailer was
who the main villain is are they just redoing
Zod again like it looks like the remaking Man of
Steel of sorts where there's no Superman so he's
able to do he's able to advance a little further
with the uh what is that machine called God damn
it whatever the machine is that he's doing to
rebuild Krypton I'm forgetting the name of it
but pal driver thing yeah yeah cool Destroyer no
that's not cool I forget it's been a long tension
uh World engine uh so yeah that
looks cool and I like things when
you know Keaton is uh doing cooler things
than he did in any of the Batman movies
because we also acknowledge how good like just
the framing and the CGI and like the actual movie
looks here because we've heard over and over again
like best thing since dark tonight which is at
this point a like Citizen Kane of superhero movies
like you say Dark Knight when you want to say
Citizen Kane like it's that thing for superhero
friends right and so I've been very worried about
just like how anything could live up to that and
though we did see a lot of this movie I'm one very
glad they didn't reveal too many cameos Beyond
like the core seemingly cast like this could be a
lot bigger but it also uh the actual composition
and the style of shot choices and again the
blending of Multiverse of directors all of that
looks like oh this is why Mushi Eddie we're
hearing is like such a force of nature director
like I've been saying give muchiati Superman
after this trailer I want it way more because
that there was some Superman shots that gave
me like like with Supergirl in that moment just
just give him Superman yeah I I love the trailer
I love the trailer Ezra looks great honestly
as it looks very emotive I like the new suit
on the third shot first I was a little worried
and then I got immediately used to it there were
a couple of shots with her to get her like that
very ending shot where they're the two berries
or I'm like uh doesn't get a little like purple
same room yeah there's a couple of uh like but
that's stuff you can easily fix that's that's not
complicated I mean it's not easy but it's that's
me it's easy for time for everything they're doing
here that's something they can fix and it's a bit
probably easier to see past in a full-on scene
where you're just sort of used to them being
together I feel like the uncanniness of that isn't
as formidable as other things can be I am curious
what the ending of this is gonna be like though
because this is supposed to reset it so is the
rumors going to be true about whatever the Batman
is at the end of this will it be the one who ends
up being the DCU Batman I still not what a great
way to cast that yeah I mean like to have that
beer Moment Like end of the movie with because
then you've got a built-in didn't have to see
this movie audience that already is there and then
you've got the we're gonna make an event in its
own way there right and you also have a way to end
uh like I've said a million times how do you end a
shared universe so what if he sacrifices himself
and stays with his mom like what if he stays in
the floating universe and then we have the Ezra's
die but then I feel like the DCU would have to
continue on in a way that's dealing with just a
bunch of cataclysmic timeline events the whole
time instead of just allowing yourself that's
exciting instead of just having like a full-on
reset I don't know we'll see uh I'm glad we don't
know bottom line is I thought it was a great
bottom line is I me personally I thought it was a
great trailer and uh I can't wait to I really I'm
really looking forward to this and the truth of
the matter is I was I've been excited for Michael
Keaton but he looked more badass than I expected
him I did not know how I'd feel about the rubber
suit coming back and I want Ben Affleck to meet
Michael Keaton so much more than I realized until
I saw them in a frame and also watch and read
Flashpoint because it does look different enough
that it won't spoil it but it also might give
you some moments of like oh that's what they're
reference like this looks different enough you
won't be ruined so check out the comic check out
the Animated Series then watch this you got time
the way how you've always drawn the analogy of a
difference between a remaking and an adaptation
this feels like a real adaptation that's also
do you know working within the universe of the
DC EU timeline yeah it's an adaptation versus
translation this this is adapting versus trying
to translate a story and they're using their
characters in a unique way like using Supergirl
in this way and I'm very curious also what that
means per in woman of tomorrow if that's the
thing yeah I don't feel like it will be that
one of course yeah this this one is a very even
even for Flashpoint serial it's a very specific
type of uh character from because even just
like Superman was I imagine that I wonder what
the thing is where where is Superman is Superman
just dead like were they come here together that's
that's my question I was like where is super gonna
see him from the chest down yeah he's out looking
for his lost head yeah he's like the headless
horse that's not the Saga yeah I'm curious I
wonder if he's just like been killed off I mean
it might not exist in that Universe what if the
the Kryptonite or the Kryptonian that gets sent to
Earth is just her and then you solve that true in
that Multiverse all right guys well what did you
think about the Flash trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a like um
and hey uh check it get some G fuel today it's
gonna be helping this individual out for a lot
of today fast is The Flash let's end this with a
Maria Hammond Maria if I had the powers of the
flash the first thing I would do is speed on over
to wherever you live go visit your family find
out what went wrong with your family and then
go all right I'm gonna time travel back in time
and go fix this to make you a sensation and on
top of that what I would do just to put a little
bit of extra whipped cream on that ice cream of
yours I would then I like that analogy I'm gonna
use that way more often now get ready for that
to be abused Maria what I would then do is uh go
back and find out what the winning numbers are for
the lottery and make sure you get that winning
ticket so that way you can succumb to all sorts
of greed and spoiling people but I hope you put
at least a third of that money into our patreon
page and I know you're good for that why would I
not just do it for myself I don't know why would
I not just use these powers to do more than help
you gain Financial Goods I don't know but that's
what I would do with it because right now I'm
looking at a box here that you got me for a
wedding present I have not yet done a video for
it you know me I want to take the proper time
to not rush through something like that but I'm
already knowing that I'm gonna love whatever the
hell's in there and I love you so thank you for
being you Maria speed on over to you soon foreign